The Joe Rogan Experience did you see
that lady on sea on 60 Minutes they
interviewed her she's uh some new
um woman who works in the white house uh
and they asked her about obesity she's
the number one cause of obesity is
genetics
and it doesn't matter what you do like
you could you could you could be a
person who has a perfect diet and
exercises and sleeps right and you're
still obese and the health experts went
[__] nuts like that's not what the
data shows the data shows that most
people who are obese have obese parents
and they come from a police family but
they're all doing the wrong thing it's
not there's not like
a person in that family that's eating
grass-fed steak and running marathons
and lifting weights and get up and
getting up at six in the morning getting
a cold plunge doing all these different
things but it's still fat as [__] yeah
and they're they're watching the
calories in and calories out and they're
burning you know a thousand calories a
day in exercise and they're still fat as
[__] that's not real like to say that
and to say it on 60 Minutes there's this
weird thing going on where people want
to say it's not your fault and it isn't
your fault I mean if you believe in
determinism if you believe in the impact
of the people around you and the
environment that you're in which is most
certainly real the impact of your
parents the impact of modeling your
modeling after other people's bad
decision making that's all real that's
100 real but to say that all obesity is
just genetic is Bonkers that's a Bonkers
thing to say and it discredits all these
people that we know that we're obese
that without surgery lost all that
weight and looked great like Ethan
suplee perfect example there was a guy
that was at one point in time like 500
plus pounds right how big was Ethan was
yet his biggest
but anyway doc Jamie will find out
documented all of it did it publicly
because he was a [__] star he's a
famous actor lost all the way now looks
great and did it through exercise and
discipline and and even like was really
open about the fact that he gained a lot
of it back a couple times he went from
550 to 255.
he did that he did that himself I mean
he he he did it and he documented it and
he had to go through surgery to get the
skin removed so that his uh you know he
wasn't like a flying squirrel but but he
did it and to say that you that it's all
genetic like no he had the same genes
like this is the same guy it's not and
it's also not inspiring yeah like uh to
say that I mean that but that's the
tension if you say it's all genetic or
it's significantly genetic then you're
encouraging people to be more accepting
of the challenges of other people's
lives like your life might be
everybody's walking A Hard Road is
basically the philosophical thing that
you don't just because it's easy for you
to exercise doesn't mean it's easy for
others to exercise sort of but aren't
they also saying you don't even have to
walk that road because it's not going to
help you exactly so that's a very poor
statement of that it's a it's a
trade-off I mean that's
it's a different philosophies pull up
pull yourself up by your bootstraps
right it's a really inspiring powerful
empowering philosophy but it's like yeah
well sometimes it's harder you can't you
can't say that because different people
have different some people don't even
[__] choose like the idea of pull
yourself up by your bootstraps is stupid
and the I did it why no no you did it
with your life the idea that your life
because it was difficult is exactly the
same in somebody else's life which may
be more difficult or have insurmountable
obstacles that are in the way there's
also like different uh temperaments
different uh mental fortitude the people
are just for whatever reason from the
womb have some people are just
determined from the time they're really
young and some people are just not some
people are discouraged easily and some
people are not and I don't know why but
to say that there's no way yeah it's
crazy to say there's no way it's like
that's irresponsible and it's also like
to say that and just put it on 60
Minutes hey guys that's not true and you
you could talk to a lot of people that
have lost weight and they'll tell you
it's not true it doesn't mean that the
people who are obese didn't get a really
bad hand genetically a really bad hand
in terms of the environment they grew up
with yeah they got dealt a bad hand no
doubt it's not the same as someone who
grows up in a house where everybody's
skinny and the [__] whole family runs
like no it's not going to be the same
someone who's eating organic and the you
know the whole family like does a lot of
exercise and does stuff together yeah
they're going to be thinner yeah but
it's like you can't lie you can't lie
and you can't be a [__] you can't
expect me to think that you're really an
expert when you say things like that
yeah but you also can't criticize Bill
Gates by saying he has a soft body of
course of course he'd be a comedian but
but he does and if he's talking about
health hey buddy get your house in order
first
yeah yeah definitely there's a lot of
incredible doctors that don't have their
house in order that's true but if you're
giving Health advice one of the core
components to health is your metabolic
Health your overall metabolical story
right out of the gate they're talking
about using the drug that some of glue
type stuff no is that what they're doing
so this is like an ad for semigluton oh
I don't I'm not saying that but that's
what it seems like oh this is even like
the whole thing about the shortages of
it oh no
well you know um I think huberman was
discussing this he might have been
discussing this with Peter attia and
they were discussing that
um semiglutide doesn't just make you
lose uh fat but also makes you lose
muscle in many cases and that's probably
because you're not taking in enough food
right because what it's doing is is I'm
just guessing it might be some other
mechanisms involved obviously but if
you're
um like full quicker which is the idea
behind this stuff it's almost like
you're taking an injection it does the
same thing as like a belly band
wouldn't I mean if you're not eating
enough food and you're losing fat that
quickly you might be losing muscle too
like because when people go on like
binge diets they starve themselves they
lose muscle like when guys lose uh
weight for fights and they get down to a
very minimalistic you know very minimal
uh calorie uh input they lose muscle too
like when someone cuts them themselves
down from like 205 and fights at 170.
one 100 they're going to lose some
muscle too yeah but there's an
interesting so for fighting is diff is
different but there's a if you're doing
it in a healthy way they're for your own
personal life there might be some
strength training combined I mean that's
a really interesting Dynamics right how
do you lose weight while maintaining
muscle mass well it depends on how much
um how many calories you're burning uh
much of the weight loss resulting from
glp-1 agonists is the loss of muscle
bone mass and other lean tissue rather
than body fat holy [__] it's dark for
example a 2021 but at least you look
good